I bought a turtleneck that shoulder pads
in it I didn't realize hobbyists there
were until I realized to have children
in it and I put it on and they're very
obvious so there's that I'm just a
fashion football player hi my name is
personal beef you don't know no your
life is different now it's time for
December favorites I didn't make this is
a wall by the way I did not make a
November favorites because I had just
been using the same stuff over and over
again but here's my December favorites
things that I've been liking recently
slightly more than other things yeah say
yeah yeah say dr. Bronner's 18 in one
hemp almond pure castile soap this is
the soap that says it basically cleans
everything on your body and in your
house which is great
all in one I love it this scent this
almond and it smells so good I can't get
over it ah this is not what I think
about when I think of almond but ah
smells are very very good and I highly
highly recommend regardless of the Bible
that is written on the outside I use it
on my body in the shower and it is the
best-selling thing I've smelled in a
long time cute Nick Massi yeah yes yeah
this is a blonde ale brightening shampoo
and conditioner by dry bar it's chain of
stores that basically do blowouts for
hair and they sell really amazing like
haircare product dry shampoo
straighteners and hair dryers and I went
to Sephora the other day and I found out
that they sell purple shampoo and purple
conditioner for blonde dyed hair I'm a
natural brunette spoiler alert maintain
blonde hair you're supposed to use
purple shampoo and purple conditioner if
you can find it I've had a lot of
trouble trying to find a purple
conditioner because it just dries out my
hair it doesn't feel soft until this one
these are $25 each I got them at Sephora
I've been using them for the last week
and I love them cute this is a Smashbox
eyeshadow palette and cover shop
metallic eye palette oh wow look at it
look at look at it I did a Sephora run
last week because I just needed an
upgrade of the stuff that I was shoving
into my pores I saw that Smashbox kind
of released a bunch of these little tiny
eyeshadow palette this one is the
metallic eye palette
oh pretty I have it on my eyes right now
look how pretty it is this is gonna be a
great travel companion because it's
compact I like it that's that cute neck
yes getting up sailing up see this was
in my recent Brooks guest is make up
prices video this is l'oreal voluminous
superstar mascara a lot of even had
questions on because in that video i
said this was $10 but on the screen it
said 24 and I've almost like is it 10 or
20 for this is and I love it basically a
double-ended dildo of mascara it has a
one and A two and the one is low white
primer brush and then two is obviously
the mascara this works so well if you
don't like using false lashes what you
want to keep your lashes a little bit
more personality then this is your
ticket so my eye lashes right now look
Wow sweater I got at Target I don't know
why I guess I just like this color green
so much for this season so that's a
favorite a cheetah print but an
unnatural cheetah print a festive
Grinchy cheetah hue festive huh but it's
by this brand a new day the targets been
recently running that I love a ton of
their clothes it's really great quality
and they're very trendy but still like
cool ala puke cheetah print so cute max
yeah can't say I am see it
this is melatonin which if you're one of
those creeps that sleep without having
to have help go piss yourself but if
you're not if you're like me and you
have really a difficult time falling
asleep then hey welcome to your new best
friend melatonin is a natural sleep aid
this is strawberry flavored my brain is
a blessing and a curse I brain is very
very active when I don't want it to be
and a long time inactive when I want it
to be active when I'm trying to fall
asleep is usually when I start thinking
about things so so much but I just I
can't get my mind to rest
recently I started taking melatonin and
it's been fantastic I had in the past
taken zzzquil to try and fall asleep but
I wake up the next morning feeling kind
of groggy and sometimes it doesn't word
lasts like we gonna have two weeks I've
been taking it and it's fantastic I fall
asleep I stay asleep that's my other big
issue is that if I do fall asleep I will
wake up in the middle of the night I
can't get back to sleep then I get the
anxiety if I should be asleep right now
and that keeps me from falling back
asleep this has been really great to
keep me asleep through the entire night
I know this seems like a drug commercial
but it's not oh it's vegetarian so
there's that I'll let you know if there
are long-term lasting effects so far the
only long-term effect is that now I like
shoulder pads oh can you take it if you
can't see it but I've been obsessed with
it 90-day fiance
it's a reality television program on TLC
I've lost so many hours of my life to it
I am furiously okay with it taking up o
my time and literally I'm going to go
back and finish watching the end of
season five I'm obsessed about people
that live in America the meet people
overseas and they want to marry them but
it
come to the United States on a k1 visa
so they have 90 days to decide in the
United States if they actually do want
to get married and then they have to get
married in that time it's bonkers I've
looked up so many of their instagrams
that I'm I I got I don't like who I've
become but I'm also okay with who I
become so that's it for this just said
we're favorites I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to click subscribe
to this YouTube channel cuz in the new
year I will be making videos at a
schedule to be determined but I got
shoulder pads so 2007 going out with a
couple more regrets other than that I
don't know I have a very active brain my
brain my brain is a bless my okay brain
I'm gonna need you to help me out with
describing new to them okay